so i started off with a nice natural  upholstered sofa and then i flanked the  sofa with two rattan chairs which are  really popular right now the other thing  that i found was a glass coffee table  that had a wooden top that ironically  also had a chevron design which would  tie into the floor  the other thing that i wanted to do was  to flank the walls with some type of  larger cabinetry so i found a beautiful  vintage like piece that has about 20  drawers where drew can put all of her  knick-knacks and whatnots and then i  wanted to kind of finish things off with  two things that you cannot leave in a  space you need a rug just to ground  everything i went with a jute rug just  because jute rugs are very durable  they're family friendly you can run  across it and they really won't get  messed up and then i finished everything  off with a beautiful chandelier just  kept it matte black and simple something  that's transitional and you can use it  for  dollhouse to dollhouse to come